At some point, every great series must come
to an end.
Sometimes you get a satisfying coda to a wonderful
experience, and sometimes that eagerly-anticipated
series finale turns out to be the loogie that
ruins the punchbowl.
As much as we all love The Walking Dead, it
can't go on forever.
When the walkers finally stop walking, how
do we think it'll all go down?
The walkers evolve
We don't really know much about zombie biology,
but we do know about viruses.
Viruses evolve, sometimes because of environmental
factors, and sometimes against human intervention.
Right now, the zombies are shambling, hungry
monsters who hunt based on smell and sound,
but what if they're capable of... becoming
more?
Zombies are strong, but they're slow, and
can only really use two senses.
The virus and the human body seem to have
a symbiotic relationship after death.
So there's nothing really stopping the virus
from mutating these guys into a whole new
kind of zombie.
Virus mutation is not altogether unlikely,
and when that happens, mankind is totally
toast.
The walkers win
There are simply far more walkers on Earth
than there are living people.
And even though humans possess superior intelligence,
they just can't seem to keep it together as
well as the brainless dead can.
Humans lack unity, and zombies have an amazing
persistence.
As we watch the last struggling group of survivors
dwindle, in a world gone wild from neglect,
they’ll eventually run out of resources.
The food options suck…
“Peanut butter and jelly, diet soda and
pigs feet.
That’s a white trash brunch right there.”
...and no one seems to really pursue farming
too seriously.
It's a pathetic, whimpering death…but it's
depressingly closer to reality than any apocalypse
we've ever seen before on TV.
If The Walking Dead is one thing, it's depressing.
The humans win
We know almost nothing about walker physiology,
other than the fact that their guts make a
great disguise.
“Oh this is bad, it’s really bad.”
They die when their brains are injured, and
they spread a zombie-making disease, but that's
really about it.
At this point, we haven't met a single zombie
that's died of natural causes, so we can only
assume that they're basically immortal if
unharmed.
But walkers are also easily killed with just
about anything pointy and well-aimed.
It's been suggested that the walkers are the
Earth's answer to environmental changes.
So if humans stop acting stupid and focus
on cleansing the world of the undead, the
planet's ecology will be better off than ever.
Zombies make amazing mulch.
It might not be great for the surviving humans
who have a hankering for pizzas rolls, but
you can't please everyone.
Cremation becomes mandatory, and mankind crawls
back to the top of the food chain.
Utopia is discovered
Between The Walking Dead and Fear the Walking
Dead, we’ve only really seen what’s happening
on the coasts.
We have no idea what's happening in the middle
states, aside from some hints from a network
of park rangers.
We also don’t have any idea about what's
happening in the rest of the world.
We've seen maybe 2% of what's really going
on out there, which leaves a lot to the imagination.
Once we know that Rick’s party is truly
safe, we'll be able to sleep at night, and
the series can end.
On Marc Maron's WTF podcast, creator Robert
Kirkman said he'd like to see the TV series
end on a positive note, so real, actual, measurable
success isn't out of the question.
A cure is found
Disease experts are in pretty short supply,
but we've seen labs and hospitals as sanctuaries.
While it seems unlikely that someone will
whip up a zombie cure and crop-dust the entire
planet with it, the discovery of something
to counteract the zombie virus would pretty
much save the world.
No, it won't restore Grandpa to normal, but
at least it'll stop him from hungering for
living flesh, which is a pretty fair compromise.
It ends with Rick
When a show loses its star, it rarely lasts
more than a couple of seasons before totally
collapsing.
Rick is really the compass of the group, even
when he's spinning wildly off course.
While characters like Daryl and Carol are
interesting to watch evolve, The Walking Dead
is Rick's story from beginning to end, and
without him, we just don't have a focal point.
Whether Rick just can't survive the thousandth
onslaught, he manages to pass from old age,
or Andrew Lincoln just decides that it's time
to go, Rick's story is the only story.
Like a canary in a coalmine, once Rick is
gone, start preparing for the bitter end.
Then again, Carl's story is also a part of
Rick's story.
We'd only like to see Rick dying in a final
episode sort of deal, where he passes the
torch of leadership to the guy who was by
his side throughout the entire zombie apocalypse,
his son.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know how
you think The Walking Dead will end...